Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khoa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube gái Excel bài số
12 special trong Excel trước khi đi vào
bài số 12 mình sẽ giải câu hỏi của bài
số 11 hôm trước nhá đây các bạn sẽ mở
cái câu hỏi lên ok ở đây mình sẽ có ba
cái câu hỏi câu hỏi thứ nhất là mình sẽ
tô màu thay đổi theo khu vực Đấy tức là
rẻ miền Bắc mình sẽ tô màu xanh miền
Trung mình sẽ tô màu vàng và miền Nam
mình sẽ tô cái màu xám ấy thì ở cái câu
hỏi số 2 ấy là mình sẽ tô màu theo cái
tỷ lệ phần trăm để từ 0 đến 50 phần trăm
hoàn thành thì sẽ ra màu xanh từ 50 đến
80 chị sẽ làm màu vàng và lớn hơn 80 thì
sẽ là màu xám đấy con cái Cách thứ ba là
mình sẽ tô màu giống như cách 2 nhưng mà
mình sẽ có cả cái giá trị ở cái phần tô
màu đấy thì đầu tiên mình sẽ làm cái câu
hỏi số 1 là mình sẽ tô màu thay đổi cho
khu vực đúng ạ thì ở đây
ý là cái sản phẩm theo khu vực Còn đây
là cái kế hoạch Đây là cái kết quả thực
hiện nhá Thì cái phần trăm hoàn thành
các bằng lại các bạn sẽ vàng là các bạn
lấy cái kết quả thực hiện các bạn chia
cho chia cho kế hoạch để các bạn enter
thì nó sẽ ra là 90 phần trăm của các bạn
thích lúc nhá thì để tô màu nha các bạn
sẽ bằng này các bạn sẽ lấy một trăm phần
trăm thì một trăm phần trăm chín mươi
một Đúng không các bạn lấy 1 - rẻ - cái
phần trong hoàn thành thì nó sẽ ra là
cái phần trăm không hoàn thành thì tại
sao mình lại dùng cái phần trăm không
hoàn thành thì lát nữa mình sẽ giải
thích cho các bạn nhé để các bạn sẽ kéo
xuống đây thì bây giờ mình sẽ tô màu cho
cái câu hỏi số 1 nhé các bạn sẽ Bôi đen
Cái vùng mà các bạn cần tô màu đúng ạ
sau đó các bạn vào thẻ hôm các bạn vào
con đi sợ nộp format tinh Các bạn chọn
Milo đây sau đó bạn sẽ tích vào cái giấy
cùng Tức là mình sẽ sử dụng công thức để
mình tạo cái định dạng có điều kiện
không ạ thì các bạn bằng nhá thì các bạn
sẽ thích vào cái ô đầu tiên của cái phần
khu vực ở đây này chính là Osram các bạn
sẽ
a123 lần Tức là mình sẽ bỏ đô la hết đi
đúng không ạ Mình sẽ áp dụng cái quy tắc
này cho các cái ô dưới này nữa đấy nếu
như hoặc bằng lượng bằng mổ kéo ra là
bằng cái khu vực Miền Bắc đó các bạn sẽ
nó khép lại nếu như bằng phía bát ngát
thì các bạn sẽ định dạng này các bạn và
format đấy các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ phim
nhá mình sẽ tô màu theo yêu cầu miền Bắc
là màu xanh lá cây đây đúng không các
bạn sẽ thích ở đây để cậu sẽ bấm ok cho
mình nhá Đợi như vậy đây là miền Bắc các
bạn xem ok đấy thì các miền Bắc đã được
tô đậm rồi tương tự mình sẽ làm cho cái
miền Trung và miền Nam là màu nhu cầu
thế này đúng ạ để các bạn vẫn có thể hô
các bạn vào con đi xe lửa pháp Marketing
Mình sẽ chọn cái lu các bạn thích xuống
dưới để sử dụng công suất nha các bạn
bằng này các bạn sẽ thích vào cái ô khu
vực ở đây là xe lam các bạn ở mép 4 1 2
3 lần hoặc bằng ghẹ bằng mở ngoặc kép ra
là miền Trung ở đây này các bạn đóng
ngoặc kép ạ nếu như ba miền chung thì
bạn sẽ format này các bạn vẫn còn thì
pin nhá ở đây là mình màu vàng văn các
Ừ Ok đã gọn của Mochi thì như vậy mình
đã tôi xong miền Bắc và miền Trung rồi
đúng không Mình sẽ làm tương tự cho miền
Nam nhé các bạn vẫn còn trẻ hôm này và
con đi xâm lược maketing vẫn là cái lu
đấy các bạn sẽ thích xuống dưới này bạn
bằng nhá các bạn thích vào cái ô C5 này
các bạn F4 cho mình 3 lần 123 đấy mặt
bằng việc bằng một phép ra các bạn sẽ
thích là gì Các bạn sẽ bằng cái miền Nam
vào đây các bạn đó chép lại nếu như bằng
miền Nam thì các bạn sẽ format này Đấy
màu xám đây các bạn sẽ thích vào cái màu
này đi đã chọn xong bấm ok các bạn Ok
thì như vậy mình đã tô màu Xong cho các
cái khu vực ở đây đúng không ạ đại nếu
mình Bắc thì là màu xanh miền Trung thì
là màu vàng và Việt Nam là màu xám thì
bây giờ tại sao mình lại kiếm phần trăm
ở đây nhá thì có bạn lại tạo một cái cái
định dạng có điều kiện nữa Cái này rất
là hay này phải có bạn bè này sau đó gọi
vào thì hôm các bạn vào con đi rừng được
phát minh Gọi Chọn newsroom I
ý thì cái này nha các bạn chọn cái trên
cùng ở đây chứ là mình sẽ định dạng theo
dựa vào cái giá trị của nó đúng không
đấy ở dưới cái format tay này các bạn sẽ
chọn cho mình là Cái đây ta ba rồi thì
gọi chú nhá ở đây cái phần trăm hoàn
thành thì thông thường nó sẽ là từ 0 đến
100 phần trăm đúng không Thì ở đây mình
sẽ có cái tùy chọn là minimap và men thì
cái kiểu mini mod là gì mình cho kiểu số
đi cái kiểu mặt maximum mình cũng chọn
kiểu số đi để cái nhỏ nhất là không có
cái lớn nhất thì sẽ là một rất là một
trăm phần trăm nữa cái Sulli pin thì
mình sẽ tô màu gì đúng không cái KL thì
mình sẽ tô màu trắng đấy Còn cái Border
đây nhá thì các bạn sẽ là lâu Golden đấy
con cái dễ cái ba dai sừn nó còn thích
vào đây các bạn xem tô việc mình cho tôi
từ phải qua trái thì lát nữa mình sẽ
giải thích cho các bạn nhá Đấy Ok các
bạn sẽ thích và cái bìa các bạn sẽ thích
vào cái sâu ba only lại là tớ là gì ạ Nó
sẽ tô màu nhưng mà nó sẽ ảnh cái giá trị
đi Tức là nó ẩn cái giá trị số đây này
lại có thể bấm ok thì à
Ừ thì cho bạn ạ đấy gọi thế chưa Lúc này
là gì ạ Bạn này đã hoàn thành 90 phần
trăm này thì cái màu xanh này nó sẽ tô
đến 90 phần trăm bạn này là 76 phần trăm
thì đây là 76 phần trăm đấy hai mươi
phần trăm thì là hai mươi phần trăm đây
lại Bây giờ các bạn xem vào thì hôm này
mình sẽ bỏ con đi sửa pháp Marketing Các
bạn chọn cái marylou này đấy thì cái lu
của mình là cái này cho ba vừa xong đúng
không Thì gọi sự tích vào cái đây cho 3
sau đó bạn chọn edit rồi bây giờ mình sẽ
giải thích cho các bạn nhé Thứ nhất là
cái sâu bio-life thế nào nó sẽ ẩn cái số
phần trăm ở đây đi đúng ạ Còn cái
minimem và maximun thì con hiểu rồi đúng
không thì thông thường cái kế hoạch hoàn
thành là từ 0 đến 100 phần trăm cho nên
mình chính là ở đây là kiểu số và từ
không đến một đấy tiếp theo là gì À cái
KL mình sẽ tô màu là việc mình sẽ tô màu
trắng này các bạn thấy cho cái phần màu
trắng ở đây là mười phần trăm thì nó sẽ
rìa nó sẽ chính là bằng một trăm phần
trăm - cần trong Hoàn thành đấy tôi là
bạn chất ở đây cái màu trắng đây này là
mình đã tô với giá trị ngược với cái giá
trị
tin tức là phần trăm chiêu Hoàn thành
đấy thì như vậy cái khoảng trắng ở đây
là phần trăm chưa hoàn thành Đấy con cái
ra Internet Thế là mình sẽ thực hiện
mình sẽ tô từ phải qua trái đây này Đấy
thì như vậy đây rất là đẹp rồi nó không
Ví dụ cái bạn này thực hiện được là diện
50 thôi nhé còn thay đổi đây đấy thì cậu
thấy chưa thì chỉ là làm ơn trong hoàn
thành Ví dụ ở đây là gì đây là 30 thôi
còn thấy cho thì chỉ có ba mươi phần
trăm hoàn thành không để rất là hai ạ Ok
mình sẽ sang cái câu hỏi số 2 ở đây cái
phần trăm hoàn thành nhá mình giả sử
mình bà mẹ mình sẽ gán là bằng cái hoàn
thành ở bên này lại các bạn enter thì nó
sẽ ra ba mươi phần trăm Ok cái tô màu
thì các bạn cũng làm ngược lại thôi các
bạn sẽ bằng đấy ạ bạn các bạn lấy 1 - gì
ạ - Cái phần trăm hoàn thành Đây thì nó
sẽ ra là còn lại là phần trăm trưởng
thành đúng không các bạn kéo xuống đây
đấy Thì bây giờ mình sẽ làm việc mình sẽ
làm giống như cách một thôi ạ thay vì
Bắc Trung Nam thì mình sẽ khống chế ở
cái ngũ hoàn thành này thì đầu tiên các
bạn sẽ gì em
Hà Nội dung mà các bạn cần tô màu nhé
sau đó bạn vào thẻ hôm này các bạn và
con disk format Pink Các bạn chọn use
đấy thì ở dưới này nhé các bạn vẫn là sử
dụng công thức Đúng không các bạn sẽ
bằng này thì đây các bạn sẽ dùng với từ
0 đến 50 phần trăm nhá lại thì bạn có
thể dùng các hàm Em đi Hà mint là gì ạ
Em của cái gì của các phần trăm hoàn
thành ở đây ạ ấy thì bọn chúng nhắc cái
này các bạn ở ghép 4 1 2 3 lần đấy nếu
như mà phần trăm hoàn thành ở đây mà dị
ạ lớn hơn hoặc bằng 0 phẩy lại thỏa mãn
điều kiện tiếp theo là gì vẫn là cái
phần trăm hoàn thành ở đây lại các bạn
f412 ba lần mà diện nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng đi
để nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng 50 phần trăm đúng
không Vậy thì gọi cho nó ngoác lại tức
là nó sẽ nằm trong khoảng từ 0 đến 50
phần trăm thì bạn sẽ pho mát đúng không
Rồi các bạn vào cái thẻ phim này mình sẽ
cho màu xanh này đi để họ sẽ không Ok
lại gọi bằng Ok thì như vậy là dị hợm
đây từng
số trang bạn thấy chứ là tô màu xanh rồi
thì các bạn chú ý nhé cái phần mà dịp
cái phần mà mình tô màu nó vẫn đang được
Ballad rồi cho nên các bạn không cần
phải bôi đen nữa các bạn vẫn có thể hôm
này các bạn chọn con đi sửa hosting mình
sẽ là lưu lại gọi sẽ chọn cái dưới này
để mình sử dụng công thức này các bạn
bằng viện vàng em em của mở ngoặc nhá
các bạn vẫn tích và cái phần trăm hoàn
thành vào đây là K5 này các bạn f412 ba
lần mà dẹp mà lớn hơn 50 phần trăm để
Tức là trong cái khoảng 50 đến 80 phần
trăm nhé Phải thì còn có thể gọi trực
tiếp luôn là K5 để chọn không cần phải
tích vào cái Ok nữa nhé Mà gì ạ Mà nhỏ
hơn hoặc bằng 80 phần trăm đúng không
Tức là trong cái khoảng thứ hai này có
sự đóng ngoặc lại để nếu như nó nằm
trong khoảng này thì họ sẽ format Tức là
mình sẽ định dạng nó đúng không Mình sẽ
chọn cái màu vàng này thì các bạn bấm ok
ok để như vậy vì xong cái màu vàng rồi
đúng không Bây giờ còn lại là lớn hơn 80
phần trăm thì mình sẽ tô màu xám đấy Các
Ừ hôm nào con đi sửa mắt tinh larue để
mình sẽ thích bạn đây sử dụng công thức
các bạn bằng này đấy ạ Ở đây cái phần
cuối cùng thì bạn không phải dùng hàm em
nữa đúng không đây Các bạn sẽ gọi là K5
luôn vẫn là cái Ok Nam đấy mà dị lớn hơn
Cám ơn phần trăm thì bạn sẽ format đấy
là màu xám đúng không Này các bạn sẽ
chọn cái môn này các bạn muốn ok ok đấy
thì như vậy mình đã tô màu rồi đúng
không Ok Bây giờ mình sẽ làm được cái
cách một nhá thì đầu tiên các bạn sẽ mua
đem cái vùng dữ liệu này đấy các bạn xem
vào đây các bạn sẽ vào thì hôm các bạn
và con đi sửa format tinh các bạn sẽ
chọn cái use đấy thì các bạn vẫn là chọn
cái trên cùng này nhá đấy cậu chết chọn
để ở đây cái phần format tay mình sẽ
chọn nó diện đây cho ba Đấy cái phần
minimem ở đây là mình sẽ chọn nó làm bờ
cái maximum đây mình sẽ là năm bờ đúng ạ
nữa thì đây là không vào đây là một rồi
cái phần khan ở đây thì mình sẽ cho màu
trắng đây cái bơ Daddy
từ bao đời đúng không các phần 3
Direction được đây nhá thì mình sẽ cho
từ phải qua trái đây các bạn sẽ thích
chọn râu boli Tức là mình sẽ không sâu
cái giá trị ở đây ra đây là 70 phần trăm
này 25 phần trăm bảy mươi phần trăm đấy
thì những cái giá trị này nó sẽ bị ẩn đi
và nó chỉ sâu cái phần diện tích của
phần trăm hoàn thành thôi nhá phải gọi
cho bố Ok đấy vẫn này chưa Nó giống hệt
với cả cái tô màu đây rồi rất là đẹp ạ
Ok Xem câu hỏi thứ ba là gì mình sẽ tô
màu thay đổi theo phần trăm hoàn thành +
giá trị đấy rất là chị ạ Cái phần trăm
hoàn thành ở đây mình cũng tô màu lên và
cái màu đây thì mình sẽ giống là cái câu
hỏi số 2 Đấy cái phần trăm hoàn thành Ví
dụ mình vẫn là bằng cái kết quả đây nhá
Đấy con kéo xuống Ok cái phần tô màu
gọng vẫn là gì vẫn là bằng 1 - cái phần
trăm hoàn thành Tức là mình sẽ Tô màu
cái phần trăm không hoàn thành là màu
trắng nữa Đấy cái phần tô màu ở đây nó
sẽ giống hệt với cái phần tô màu đây thì
cách đơn giản là gì Các bạn sẽ Bôi đen
Cái vùng dữ liệu mà các bạn ở tô màu
chiếc đấy Này các bạn chọn
sự kiện ở đây này các bạn xem tiếp vào
cái chổi trong cái thẻ hôm nhá Để sau đó
còn sẽ format cho cái phần câu hỏi số 3
đây Đấy thấy chưa Nó sẽ giống hệt cái
này rồi lại rất là hai ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ
Tô màu cái số này này đấy thì nó màu nó
giống như thế này thì các bạn rất là đơn
giản các bạn Bôi đen Cái cùng dữ liệu ở
đây đấy các bạn xem vào thì các bạn và
thẻ hôm các bạn và con disk format tinh
Các bạn chọn resolve đấy Ở đây mình sẽ
thích cái dưới này để mình sử dụng công
thức nha các bạn sẽ bằng điện bằng em em
của mở ngoặc nhá Thì cái phần trăm hoàn
thành Đây chính là gì chính là cái kia
Nam các bạn ạ f412 ba lần mà diện mà lớn
hơn hoặc bằng không phải dạng vẫn là phê
lắm các bạn gõ luôn là bên năm mà dị nhỏ
hơn hoặc bằng diện 50 phần trăm các bạn
sẽ đóng ngoặc lại nếu như mà thỏa mãn
các điều kiện này tức là nó sẽ nằm trong
khoảng từ 0 đến 50 phần trăm thì chọn
format đấy thì gọi thêm vào cái phần
phone nhé mình
hai chữ thôi Mình sẽ không tô màu cái ô
ở đây thì bạn sẽ là tô đậm này và các
bạn cho phần KL ví dụ là mình trong màu
xanh này đi lại họ sẽ bảo OK các bạn sẽ
bấm ok đấy thì nó sẽ màu xanh tương ứng
với bên này tương tự bây giờ mình sẽ làm
cho cái màu cam nhé các bạn lại Bôi đen
Cái vùng dữ liệu đây mình vẫn và thẻ hôm
con nên sơ lược marketing Nero lại ra sự
tích vào đây để mình sử dụng công thức
này các bạn bằng em em của mở ngoặc nhá
thì vẫn là cái Ok năm đúng không Mà gì ạ
Mà lớn hơn 50 phần trăm phẩy và rẻ vẫn
là cái B5 mà diện nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng gì
80 phần trăm phải thì bạn sẽ nóng hoặc
lạnh các bạn sẽ format cho nó mình sẽ
vào cái thẻ phone nhá Chữ đậm này vì rất
color mình sẽ cho nó máu và bé gạch bấm
ok ok đấy Gọi cho cái giá trị ở đây nó
là màu vàng
Ừ cái phần tô màu rồi chỉ còn lại là cái
màu của lớn hơn 80 phần trăm thôi bạn
Bôi đen này và thẻ hôm conditional
formatting lại chọn im ru đấy mình tích
vào đây để sử dụng công thức nhắc các
bạn bằng ghẹ thì với các trường hợp cuối
này các bạn không cần phải dùng hàm em
nữa tại vì nó chỉ có một cái giá trị là
lớn hơn 80 phần trăm đúng không đấy thì
làm vi nam diện lớn hơn 80 phần trăm Hãy
thì các bạn sẽ format lại gọn xem vào
cái thẻ phone mình sẽ tô đậm và mình sẽ
cho màu là gì ạ đây ví dụ là màu sáng
nay đi Bạn muốn Ok Ok đó cảm thấy chứ
rất là hai ạ Ok như vậy là mình đã xong
cái câu hỏi của bài số 11 nhá Thì bây
giờ Họ sẽ đóng lại mình cho vào cái bài
tập số 12 của hôm nay các bạn chú ý nhé
mình sẽ để cái link tải file thực hành
trong phần mô tả cái dưới video thì tốt
nhất là các bạn tải về các bạn vừa theo
dõi và nữ
Ừ nếu như bạn nào mà không biết cách tải
về thì các bạn xem lại cái bài đầu tiên
thì trong bài đấy mình đã hướng dẫn các
bạn là cách chi tiết để các bạn tải về
nhá Thì cái file mà mình tải về sẽ là
file nén nó sẽ có 2 file 1 file file
thực hành chính là cái file mà các bạn
đang xem này và cái file thứ 2 là cái
file câu hỏi để các bạn làm bài tập về
nhà nhá Đấy thì trong bài tập ngày hôm
nay mình sẽ sử dụng cái kết cho dù trong
Excel thì nội dung của hôm nay sẽ gồm 10
cái ứng dụng của cái kết Castle luôn đấy
castell nghĩa là gì Nghĩa là mình chưa
dán đặc biệt để Thông thường thì các bạn
hãy copy Tuyết nhé ví dụ các bạn copy
Kyo này các bạn nháy thì phải gọi copy
đoạn trích ra đây này các bạn có thể ấn
can trên V thì đây là cái kết thông
thường thôi đúng không còn cái kết đặc
biệt là gì xinh nháy chuột phải vào một
ô mà các bạn cần Tuyết Các bạn chọn
Tuyết cao su đấy thì trong Bài học này
Hôm nay mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn 10 ứng
dụng rất là hay của cải quyết cho số này
nhá ở đây mình sẽ ấn cancel đi lại bị
xóa cái này đi
Ừ thì mỗi một cái ứng dụng sẽ ở một cái
shit tiếng Việt đúng không Thì đầu tiên
Vì sẽ làm Rẻ mình sẽ sử dụng cái copy
format thì giả sử đây là cái format của
cái 5 năm 2020 đấy Cái format này mình
đã làm rất là đẹp rồi chẳng hạn thì nhá
Thì bây giờ mình có dữ liệu của năm 2021
nó sẽ giống như là cái format của năm
2020 nhưng mà nó vẫn là ở đây là cái
kiểu của nó là dữ liệu thôi nó chưa có
tô màu hay là kẻ khung gì cả đúng không
Bây giờ mình muốn áp cái format Tức là
cái định dạng của cái 5 20 20 này cho
520 21 thì mình làm như thế nào đấy thì
đầu tiên là bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ
liệu ở đây rồi còn sẽ nhớ về phải này
các bạn sẽ copy đấy Sau đó các bạn Bôi
đen Cái vùng mà dữ liệu các bạn muốn
định dạng giống như cái phần mà mình
copy ở đây nhá các bạn sẽ nhấn chuột
phải này các bạn chọn biết perso đấy và
các bạn sẽ thích chọn là gì Các bạn sẽ
thích chọn là pháo mát ở đây để tiếc là
mình chưa biết cái format ở bên này sang
bên này luôn đấy Bạn bấm ok đấy
vì vậy nó lấy nguyên cái định dạng của
bên này Đấy Ok xanh chạy ứng dụng thứ
hai của cái pass cho dù là gì ạ Mình sẽ
có cái danh sách chọn xuống ở đây đấy
thì giả sử mình có Đây là cái danh sách
xổ xuống nhá Đây này các bạn sẽ tích vào
cái hình tam giác ở đây này cái danh
sách xổ xuống ở đây nó sẽ có cái kiểu
giới tính ví dụ là các bạn chọn nữ thì
nó sẽ là nữ hoặc là Nam thì là Nam hoặc
các bạn có thể chọn khác ở đây đấy thì
cái này gọi là cái danh sách xổ xuống
hay còn gọi là dropdownlist nhá Thì bây
giờ cái giới tính ở đây nó chưa có tùy
chọn đúng không ạ Bây giờ làm sao để
mình copy được cái danh sách xổ xuống từ
đây từ bên này sang bên này Đấy cách rất
đơn giản các bạn sẽ thích vào cái ô mà
nó đã có cái danh sách xổ xuống rồi đúng
không các bạn nhảy chuột phải là các bạn
chọn copy đấy Bây giờ con bọ đen cái
phần giới tính mà các bạn định p đúng
không để còn nhỏ rất phẳng Các bạn chọn
vestal đấy thì gọi sẽ chọn vào rìa Các
bạn chọn và cái validation ở đây để gọi
sẽ bảo Ok đấy chứ Thì như vậy
ý của từng cái họ tên này nó đã có cái
danh sách xổ xuống ở đây để chọn rồi
đúng không Ví dụ gãy sẽ sáng là Nam để
các bạn thích và gà đi theo 7 là nữ đợi
gãy CO2 ở đây ví dụ là giới tính khác
đời thì cứ như vậy nha các bạn đã có một
cái danh sách sổ hướng rồi là rất là hai
ạ cái cách mà tạm một cái danh sách xổ
xuống này như thế nào ấy thì sau này về
cái phần thủ thuật thì nghỉ sớm nói cái
phần này cho các bạn thì trong bài học
hôm nay thì tiện thể mình sẽ nói luôn
bây giờ ví dụ Cái ô này mình cần tạo cái
giấy kính như cái ôm bên này nhá thì các
bạn sẽ thích vào cái ô đây sau đó toàn
vào thẻ data Các bạn chọn rẻ
data-validation ở đây đấy thì trong cái
thẻ setting này cái mục câu lâu bạn sẽ
chọn cho mình là Lead đấy các bạn sẽ
tích và cái quần sọt và các bạn gõ các
cái kiểu giới tính khác nhau đúng không
Ví dụ ở đây là nam này nó phải nữ này
lại phải khác nhá đại Ví dụ mình có ba
cái kiểu dự tính này các bạn sẽ bấm ok
đấy còn thấy chưa thì như vậy là cái ôm
này nó đã có cái danh sách xổ xuống rồi
lại rất là hai ạ
Em tải ứng dụng thứ ba là mình sẽ
Converse đấy thì giả sử những cái số
liệu ở đây là số dương bây giờ mình muốn
chuyển cái cái cái số này thành số âm
thì mình nhạc như thế nào thì rất đơn
giản nữa các bạn sẽ tạo một cái số vào
đây là cái số âm một nhá sau đó gọn nhớ
phải vào đây Các bạn chọn copy đấy Bây
giờ các bạn Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà
các bạn muốn chuyển từ số dương xanh
siêu âm này để các bạn có thể nhớ hết
phải các bạn chọn kết Castle này các bạn
sẽ chọn cái Monte flag đấy thì nghĩa là
gì Nghĩa là cái ô mà mình Bôi đen để
mình biết Cho số này nó sẽ nhân với cái
ô mà lúc đấy mình kaki chính là nhân với
ông một cái thì nghĩa là nó sẽ chuyển về
số âm gái gọi sếp bấm ok đấy thì như vậy
toàn bộ cái xuống đây đã chuyển về hội
âm ngược lại rất là hai ạ Tiếp theo là
cái transpose thì ví dụ ở đây cái dữ
liệu của mình nó đang được bố trí theo
chiều dọc Thế là cho cột đúng ạ Bây giờ
mình muốn chuyển cái dữ liệu của mình
thành hành để thì mình làm như thế nào
đấy thì mình sẽ trang bầu Tức là mình sẽ
biết cho dù là Trang
em dùng số liệu này nhá chỉ đầu tiên các
bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà các
bạn muốn trang Tông tức là muốn chuyển
hàng thành cột hoặc là cô Thành Hà Nội
các bạn sẽ nhấn chuột phải các bạn chọn
copy đấy Sau đó các bạn chọn cái ô mà
các bạn muốn sâu nhắc Ví dụ mình chọn
cái ô E3 này mình muốn transport Đến đây
lại còn nhớ được phải các bạn chọn paste
special và các bạn tích chọn là cái
trang store lại Bây giờ các bạn bấm ok
để gọi thấy chưa Chỉ cái dữ liệu của
mình ở đây đang là cột thì mình sẽ
chuyển thành hạ đây là hàng theo họ tên
có nên là hàng doanh thu đấy rất là hay
còn đang từ hàng mà bạn muốn chuyển
thành cột nhá các bạn Bôi đen cái phần
hàng này các bạn ấy thì phải các bạn
copy các bạn tích vào cái ô mà các bạn
muốn chuyển đổi thành cột nha các bạn
nhớ phải piece Special Các bạn bấm
transport đấy ok đấy thì nó lại chuyển
về hiện đang từ hàng thành về cột Tiếp
theo là cái value nhá thì giả sử ở đây
mình có cái đơn giá là đô bây giờ mình
chuyển về Việt Nam đồng thì ví dụ cái tỷ
giá hiện tại đang là 23
Ý mình là ví dụ thôi thì bạn sẽ suy ra
được ở đây Việt Nam đồng là bao nhiêu
đấy Bây giờ mình muốn cái giá trị này nó
cố định nó không là công thức nữa đấy
còn thấy cho con chó thì nó sẽ thực hiện
cũng rất là B6000 23.3 bây giờ mình muốn
cái này thành ra lưu nhá tức là khi bạn
sửa một cái số bắt kìa đây là ví dụ mình
sửa lấy hai bạn thì cái giá trị này nó
không thay đổi đúng không Thì bây giờ
gọi Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà bạn muốn
con Thành vali là các bạn nghe hiện phải
Coffee đấy còn Nhật phải các bạn chọn
vessel đấy và các bạn sẽ chọn cái vali ở
đây Các bạn bấm ok đợi thì như vậy Ở đây
nó thành cái giá trị rồi nó không phải
là công thức nữa Ok xanh cái ứng dụng
thứ sáu là mình sẽ copy cái độ rộng cột
thì giả sử như cái độ rộng của cái quý 1
Tức là cái cột C này này là độ rộng này
là đẹp rồi mình muốn ba cái túi này thứ
hai thứ ba cái bốn độ rộng nó đang khác
nhau nó cùng độ rộng với quý 1 đợi thì
các bạn làm như thế nào thì các bạn sẽ
tích vào một ô bất kỳ của cái cột C này
nhá đầy sau đó bạn nhớ là phải còn copy
Bôi đen 32 ô là gì từ D6 đến S6 này ạ
thì các bạn sẽ nhớ về phải các bạn chọn
special đấy và các bạn thích và cái rĩa
her which tức là tiệm mình sẽ copy cái
độ rộng của cái cột C này cho ba cái cột
df đấy bạn sẽ bấm ok đấy còn thấy chưa
thì như vậy ba cái cột des này Nó sẽ độ
rộng cột nó gái luôn bằng cái cuộc sống
này sang đây ứng dụng tiếp theo là mình
sẽ chuyển cách thành số thì bạn chú ý
nha Giả sử đây là cái số liệu doanh thu
của các bạn này chỉ thông thường các dữ
liệu mà các bạn X3 từ hệ thống ra ạ thì
nhìn vậy thì có ảnh hưởng là số thôi
Nhưng mà thực ra nó không phải là số đây
à nếu như là số ví dụ các bạn Nhật 97 ở
đây Nếu như là số thì nó sẽ làm ở bên
phải Còn đây là nằm ở bên trái rồi cho
nên Đây là cái Tết chứ không phải là số
đấy Bây giờ mình muốn chuyển cái này về
số thì các bạn làm như thế nào đây thì
mình sẽ tạo một cái ô ở bên ngoài nhà
cái số một nhá Đợi các bạn tin nhắn thì
phải các bạn copy cái số một này sau đó
các bạn Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà các
bạn muốn nó chuyển thành số đấy các bạn
sẽ nhắn được
Các bạn chọn paste special lại bạn sẽ
chọn làm entreprise đây các bạn xem bấm
ok thì như vậy các cái tech5 vừa xong ấy
thì nó sẽ nhấn ngồi ở đây lại thịt nó sẽ
tự động chuyển về số luôn sẽ rất là hai
ạ tiếp theo là mình muốn thêm các giá
trị vào vùng cái giá trị đang có đúng ạ
thì bây giờ giả sử mình có doanh thu
từng ngày nhé bây giờ mình muốn bổ sung
doanh thu rất là Cái ô này sẽ được tăng
thêm là ba trăm ô này sẽ được tăng thêm
mà 200 Đấy thì mình làm như thế nào Đầu
tiên các bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu
mà các bạn cần bổ sung này các bạn nháy
chuột phải các bạn copy Sau đó các bạn
Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà bạn muốn nó
được tăng thêm của các phần bổ sung Ở
đây các bạn nháy phải các bạn chọn
brussel và các bạn chọn cái S đây kệ ở
đây nghĩa là gì những cái dữ liệu cũ này
nó sẽ được tăng thêm cái phần bổ sung
rồi ta có thể bấm ok đấy còn đấy chứ nó
sẽ được tăng thêm thì đang là 97 tăng
thêm 300 thành 397 được à
ở xa cái ứng dụng tiếp theo là mình sẽ
chuyển Lumpur về phần trăm giả sử mới
nhắc quyết định cái ở đây là phần trăm
mà trong khi các bạn Nhập vào các bạn
lại thiếu cái chữ phần trăm bây giờ mình
muốn chuyển là diện 97 thành 97 phần
trăm năm mươi tám thành 58 phần trăm thì
mình làm như thế nào thì mình sẽ tạo một
cái ô có giá trị là 100 các bạn nhé chia
phải lại các bạn copy cái ô 100 này sau
đó bạn Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà các
bạn muốn chuyển về thành dạng phần trăm
nhá các bạn nháy chuột phải các bạn chọn
thistle và bạn chọn cái device này tức
là gì ạ Tức là những cái ô ở bên lành là
cái danh thu nó sẽ chia cho một trăm vào
đây đấy Gọi cho bấm ok để tìm nó sẽ
chuyển về cái kết quả là diện đang 97 nó
chuyển về thành công chấm chín bậc đó
thì ở đây rất đơn giản các bạn vào thì
hôm này các bạn chọn phần trăm nữa là
sau đây Thì như vậy Lúc đấy là 97 đã
được chuyển về chính 7 phần trăm năm
mươi tám đã được chuyển về 58 phần trăm
rất là hai ạ Ok mình sẽ xa cái ứng dụng
cuối cùng ứng dụng thứ 10 Tức là mình
muốn tăng 15 phần trăm mỗi giá trị ở đây
đấy thì để
ở phần trăm mỗi giá trị ở đây mình sẽ
tạo một cái ở đây là thế ạ Mình sẽ lấy
một trăm phần trăm + mấy cái phần trăm
mà mình muốn tăng thêm thế nào đây là
tăng thêm 15 phần trăm thì mình sẽ lấy
một trăm phần trăm cộng với cả 15 phần
trăm đấy thì nó sẽ ra kết quả là 115
phần trăm các bạn sẽ nhấn chuột phải vào
cái ô 115 phần trăm vào đây là các bạn
sẽ Coffee sau đó bạn Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ
liệu mà bạn muốn tăng lên 15 phần trăm
nhá các bạn nhảy rất phải này các bạn
chọn hết cho show đấy và các bạn bấm rẽ
Các bạn bấm apply tức là bản chất là cái
giá trị này nó sẽ nhân thêm 115 phần
trăm được thì nghĩa là nó tăng thêm 15
phần trăm các bạn sẽ bậm ok đấy thì như
vậy đây là giá trị về phần trăm nha các
bạn có thể vào thì hôm các bạn thích và
cái dấu phẩy ở đây tức là mình sẽ chuyển
về cái dạng bình thường là dạng số thôi
đợi thì cái số này nó đã được tăng lên
thành 115 phần trăm được rất là hai ạ
thì như vậy mình đã xong cái bài hướng
dẫn của hôm nay nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ xem
cái phần câu hỏi nó như thế nào Câu hỏi
của bài số 12 này à
Ừ đấy thì ở đây mình sẽ dùng ba cái sít
thế nào mình sẽ có ba cái câu hỏi cho
cái bài Sống 12 nhé Tức là mình sẽ
chuyển diện mình sẽ chuyển cái doanh thu
này về dạng số với hai cách một là mình
thêm số 0 hoặc là nói trên cho một Đúng
rồi đấy thì cái cách mà mình hướng dẫn
lúc nãy vừa xong là mình nhiên lĩnh một
bây giờ mình sẽ làm niệm mình sẽ chuyển
cái tích thành số dựa vào hai cái cách
này chúng mình sẽ thêm 01 chia cho một
cái ví dụ thứ hai của bài tập về nhà là
gì mình muốn bớt lại thì ở cái kia là
mình tăng thêm thì cái câu hỏi về nhà là
bây giờ mình muốn giảm đi Tức là 397
mình muốn giảm đi 300 thì nó phải còn là
chỉ vậy thôi là Cái ô này nó phải giảng
về là 97 đúng không Này phải giảm đi 200
thì nó sẽ còn nó 58 đấy tiếp theo là
mình giảm 15 phần trăm đấy thì cái hướng
dẫn vừa xong mà mình tăng 15 phần trăm
thì bây giờ là bớt đi 15 phần trăm thì
mình làm như thế nào đây là ba cái câu
hỏi của bài số 12 nhé Ok như vậy là mình
đã kết thúc bài học ngày hôm nay ở đây
cảm ơn các bạn đã theo
chào các bạn nhỏ đăng kí kênh để cập
nhật video mới nhất của gà cũng như chia
sẻ để giúp mọi người cùng học Excel nhé
Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại ở